We'd calculated the circumference of the earth.
That's a huge accomplishment but now let's move on. Let's calculate the size of the moon.
Here I've drawn a little diagram of what's going on with the earth, the moon, and the sun.
Now keep in mind that this is not the scale at all.
In fact the sun should be way, way, way bigger and way, way, way farther off the screen.
In fact if I drew this right, these rays would all be more or less completely parallel.
The idea behind measuring the size of the moon is we can exploit the fact that lunar eclipses occur.
Now, what's a lunar eclipse? Well, here's the sun and here are few of its rays which I've traced.
You can see that if you were in your spaceship flying around over here or here or there,
you'd would be illuminated, you would be in the sun's rays
and everything would be bright and wonderful.
As soon as you got behind the earth, however, things get dark. You're in the earth's shadow.
The same things happens to the moon.
What we want to do is figure out how big is the moon compared to the earth
since we know the size of the earth already.
Can we fit one, two, three moons in one earth shadow?
If that were the case, then the moon would be one-third the size of the earth
or is it two moons in the earth shadow or seven or 12--I don't know, let's figure that out.
How are we going to answer this question, "How many moons fit in the earths shadow?"
All we're going to do is time how long the moon spins in the earth's shadow,
how long we can't see it for during a total lunar eclipse.
The longer time it spins, the smaller the moon is compared to the earth.
Once we know how much time the moon spins in the earth shadow,
I can convert that into moon widths, let's call it.
What I mean by a moon width? I mean this distance here. That's one moon width.
We have to know how long does it take the moon to move from here
over to here, to move one moon width in its orbit.
We can answer that by noting the fact that the moon has an angular size
in the sky of about half a degree. What do I mean by that?
If you're standing on earth and if you first look at the top of the moon
then look at the bottom of the moon, this angle here is 0.5 degrees.
We also know that it takes 28 days for one complete orbit.
In 28 days, it's gone 360 degrees so that means it's gone 720 moon widths since each width
is only a half a degree and 720 is twice 360 which means 28 days per 720 moon widths,
and if we do some unit conversion that works out to be 0.93 hours for one moon width.
Every 0.93 hours, the moon has moved one width over.
So it's gone from here to here or from here to here, etc.
Now, I'm just going to give you the data.
I'm going to tell you what we can observe, and you're going to have to do
some thinking and probably some unit conversion to answer this question.
The observed fact is the following.
The moon spins 205 minutes in eclipse and what do I mean for the moon to be in eclipse?
Well, we start the eclipse timer when the moon is completely in the earth shadow
and end it just as it's leaving the earth shadow.
Okay, we know the moon takes 0.93 hours to go one moon width and we know
it spins 205 minutes in eclipse and we know earth's circumference is equal to 40,000 kilometers.
Now I think you can answer the question--now how many moons fits in the earth shadow?
Do it one step better,"What is the circumference of the moon?"
Enter you're answer here in kilometers.